[Applause]
today's video of the day comes to us
from a senate hearing inside the
hallowed Halls of Congress Oklahoma's
Mark Wayne Mullen and Teamsters
president Shan O'Brien had a history of
Bad Blood insulting each other for
months and today it finally came to a
head as you can see a bald
head thank God Bernie was there
what let me read what the last one said
um it said greedy CEO who pretends like
he
self-made sir I wish you was in the
truck with me when I was building my
plumbing company myself and my wife was
running the office because I sure
remember working pretty hard in long
hours pretends like he's self-made what
a clown fraud always has been always
will be quit the tough guy act in these
Senate hearings you know where to find
me any place anytime
cowboy sir this is a time this is a
place you want to run your mouth we can
be to consenting adults we can finish it
here okay that's fine perfect you want
to do it now I'd love to do it right now
well stand your butt up then you stand
your butt up hold stop it is that your
solution every p no no sit down sit down
you know you're a United States Senator
sit down okay sit down please all right
can I respond hold it hold
it if we can no I have the I'm sorry
this is what said you'll have your time
okay can I respond oh no you
[Laughter]
can't I love cat you got to love old man
Sanders yeah you know he could have been
a great president he won the fight he
won the fight were you happy to see two
old men fighting over something besides
you no I kind of missed the
attention um no and you know what's
crazy to watch that too Bernie Sanders
he won the fight without he didn't stand
up he didn't even lift his head no okay
and he didn't even break a sweat and
also that man is older than Joe Biden is
yes exactly older than Joe Biden it's I
always say this is not an age thing it
is that regardless of your age you got
to know where you
are I think for most jobs right I don't
think that's a lot to ask most jobs
that's like not even on the requirements
cuz it's just implied Chandler isn't it
like this is I hate to sound sexist but
this is like how men always a fight
could just break out at any because
nobody knows how to deescalate oh yeah
oh yeah and that's you need to have some
kind of other influence Mark Wayne
thinks he's Bruce Wayne okay it was it's
better than daytime television it's
better than the Kardashians yeah that
that was juicy yeah it was juicy Bernie
did shut it down I was actually
impressed by that you're absolutely
right cat he he could he can shut it
down yeah I have a theory on that all
right tell us your theory well wait you
interviewed yeah I don't want to make
this all about me or my nationally
syndicated talk show Fox Across America
um
but I did have Senator Mullen on my show
today and I'll tell you right after the
escalation occurred he called into my
show because he's a regular on the show
first and foremost you need to know this
he is a former mixed martial arts
fighter he's a professional fighter so
he would have whooped that guy's ass
pretty bad this has been going on since
the summer Bernie only broke it up
because he wanted to sell tickets to the
fight to show people how capitalism
leads to
violence you know that's the case but
you know the thing is about Mullen and
this part is you know it's kind of
important I think when you think about
it okay is this guy has been bullying
people in Oklahoma that's what this
stems from he called him out over the
summer and what Mullen said is Bernie
goes you're not acting like a United
States Senator but he said I'm a guy
from Oklahoma first and if you bully
people in Oklahoma they're coming at you
Cowboy is what he said but everybody
screaming in the chamber like oh this is
so much division this is a real division
in the 1700s they settled disputes in
the Senate by shooting each other and
the right and the winner lived and the
loser voted Democrat in the next
election you know what I mean so I don't
know I I'm with I'm Pro Mullen and not
just cuz he calls into the best radio
show in America am I right ah shut up
take that Gutfeld shut up they love him
Tyrus you know what I love about this is
that this was like everybody wants to
confront the person who tweets like so
the guy had tweet the guy tweeted the
other guy and the guy finally got him in
front of him everybody kind of wants to
do that yeah listen again like the
previous thing with drugs obviously no
one else in here has been in a fight
um so when he said get your butt up yeah
and the ball guy's rebuttal was no you
get your butt up the fight is over yeah
okay he Domin cuz what happens is if if
someone said to me get up I'm going to
get up yeah cuz that means it's go time
yeah now if I didn't want to fight I
would say no you get up and then when he
got up and walked to me now you're being
childish yeah so after that was over the
ball guy gave Bernie the biggest hug in
the world thank you thank you so much
thank you so much he did because he ran
his mouth and when the guy said you want
to handle it right here he had nowhere
to go his body language he never took
his hands off the thing he never because
I'm mad at Bernie wrong if I'd have been
in that S no no no Let Them Fight let's
get something let's get something
settled tonight with this ends here and
I would start a new thing when these
so-called senators and congressmen get
up there and they talk they go back and
forth we can't figure anything out cool
Mortal Kombat let's go then we'll
finally get some things done
Bernie they should just immediately a
cage lower yes love it a trident a
baseball bat no hitting in the face
everything else is fine and then AOC
comes on with the card it's perfect and
and listen sexist would say that but
listen and if it gets too ugly Bowman
can pull the fire alarm yes there you
go all right we got to move on this is
amazing would you be willing to eat
Oreos with let's fill in hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else